Okay, bitte gerne.
Gut. Alles klar.
Okay, ich fange an.
Ja.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Cheryl Aydin.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Szenarstätik.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstanden, verstehen oder etwas...
Verstehen, ja.
Geben Sie mir bitte Bescheid.
Okay.
Zuerst frage ich ganz kurz zu Ihrer Person.
Dann würde ich Ihren Beschwerden zu.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Petra Schmidt.
Petra Schmidt.
Können Sie bitte vor Ihren, vor uns nachnamen?
Langsam büsterbüro.
Ja.
Petra mit P-E-T-R-A.
Petra.
Okay.
Und der Nachname Schmidt.
S-C-H-M-I-D-T.
Schmidt.
Der, der. Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Entschuldigung. Sind Sie weiblich oder männlich?
Frau Schmidt.
Petra.
Petra ist männlich. Petra ist weiblich.
Okay, Frau Schmidt.
Wie alt sind Sie?
29.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 14. Juni 1992.
14. Juni 1902.
90.
90. Okay.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
62 kg.
69 kg.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 71.
Okay, gut, Frau Schmidt.
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe seit zwei Tagen habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Und die sind aber in den letzten Stunden ganz schlimm geworden,
ganz stark geworden.
Und die sind in den letzten Stunden ganz schlimm geworden.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Zu rechts, rechts,
in mir unten, rechts im Bauch.
Und die waren,
Anfangs waren sie mehr am Bauchnabel.
Da haben sie begonnen.
Aber dann zogen sie jetzt in den letzten Stunden nach rechts.
Ja.
Jetzt sind die Schmerzen im rechten Unterbau.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala?
Wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspielt.
Also, ich würde sagen gestern, am ersten Tag waren sie so bei 4 bis 5.
Aber jetzt in den letzten Stunden bei 7 bis 8.
7 bis 8.
Okay.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genügend beschreiben?
Sie sind eher dumpf, oder ist das schon, oder ist das auch?
Sie sind mehr so dumpfe Schmerzen.
Manch bei etwas stärker, aber mehr so dumpf.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie gegenseitig etwas einen Genom?
Nein, ich habe nur eine Wärmflasche genommen, etwas Wärme.
Und das war gar nicht gut. Die Wärme hat das noch schlimmer gemacht.
Schlimmer gemacht.
Haben Sie eher Fieber gemessen?
Fieber habe ich gemessen, aber erst vor 2 Stunden,
weil ich es ein bisschen auch schüttelfrost hatte.
Und da hatte ich 38,6 im Mund.
Im Mund.
Wann haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Nur vor 2 Stunden.
Okay.
Im Mund.
Stimmt.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie Stärflos haben?
Ja, hatte ich.
Aber jetzt erst seit einigen Stunden, vorher nicht.
Gestern hatte ich kein Schüttelfrost.
Ist die schwindelig oder übel?
Windelig ist mir nicht aber übel.
Übel ist mir schon, aber ich habe bisher nicht erbrochen.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Haben Sie etwas gegessen?
Nein, in den letzten Stunden hatte ich keinen Appetit.
Da habe ich nichts gegessen, nur ein bisschen etwas getrunken.
Haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches gegessen?
Heute oder gestern?
Nein, glaube ich nicht.
Haben Sie eine Schmerzstrahlung?
Nein, Sie sind eigentlich nur im Baus.
Sie haben eine Schmerzstrahlung angefangen,
und dann haben Sie einen Biomobiliabestellung gemacht.
Meiner Mitte fiel angefangen.
Und in den letzten Stunden sind Sie nach rechts gezogen.
Oke.
Im Augenblick, ich fühle mich sonst auch immer eigentlich ganz gesund, so richtig krank bin ich eigentlich nie gewesen.
Gibt es einen Auslöser für die Schmerzen, zum Beispiel bei der Bewegung, weil die Schmerzen schlimmer, oder?
Ja, ich gehe nicht gerne rum oder Treppen steigen war nicht gut zu Hause.
Ich lege mich lieber auf die Sofa hin und ziehe die Knie etwas an.
Das Beste.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stolack?
Nein, das habe ich kein Problem.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Normal, ja. Die letzte Nacht habe ich nicht so gut geschlafen wegen der Bauchschmerzen.
Sonst schlafen Sie gut?
Okay, verstanden. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich habe immer mein Gewicht in letzter Zeit gehalten.
Okay, schießen Sie übermäßig?
Nein, ich schwitze nur, wenn ich etwas sportmache, sonst schocke ich etwas.
Ich habe zwei Mal die Woche joggen, eine Stunde jeweils.
Taschwitz, sonst schwitze ich nicht viel.
Okay, verstanden.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen von denen ich wissen sollte?
Im Frühjahr habe ich Heuschnupfen, ein bisschen Allergie auf Polen.
Was ist das alles? Birkenpolen und Gräser?
Da muss ich dann manchmal einen Astmasch brei nehmen, aber nur im Frühjahr, sonst nicht.
Okay.
Wie heusert sich Ihre Heuschnupfen?
Ich habe eine Nase und dann Augen tränen, Nase, aber manchmal auch etwas Luftnotes.
Wenn ich dann joggen will, dann muss ich vorher einen Astmasch brei nehmen.
Okay. Kennen Sie deinen Namen vom Astmasch brei?
Das sind zwei Verschiedene.
Ich habe einen Cortison-Sprei und einen normalen Astmasch brei, aber ich kann den Namen jetzt Ihnen nicht nennen.
Okay.
Sie werden für diese Medikamente nur bei Bedarf, nicht regelmäßig.
Nur bei Bedarf.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen außerhalb von Asthma und Heuschnupfen?
Nein, ich vertrage Nüsse nicht so gut, die meid ich.
Nüsse muss ich aufpassen, da kriege ich manchmal einen brennenden Mund und ein bisschen Ausschlag im Mund.
Aber sonst geht es mir gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Krankheiten?
Nein, ich bin noch nie operiert worden, war eigentlich noch nie im Krankenhaus.
Okay, wann sind Sie operiert worden?
Noch nie. Okay.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Krankenhaus gewesen?
Nein, noch nie, heute zum ersten Mal.
Okay, sehr gut.
Nehmen Sie außerhalb Cortison-Sprei und Asthma-Sprei.
Noch andere ganz welche Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Okay, sehr gut.
Sie habe schon gesagt, dass Sie Allergie haben, gegen Polen.
Haben Sie noch andere Allergie?
Nur gegen Nüsse.
Sie äußert sich durch Ausschlag und Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, Nüsse ist mehr so brennenden Mund auf der Diagnose.
Manchmal habe ich dann auch so Bläschen im Mund.
Okay, bitte.
Rauchen Sie Frauchen?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Vielleicht mal am Wochenende ein Glas Wein, aber das ist selten.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie mich persönlich, das ist eine routine Frage.
Konsumieren Sie Droge?
Nein.
Hat jemand in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Wie zum Beispiel, wie ist die Krankheit?
Meine Mutter ist 56 Jahre alt.
Sie hat Asthma, meine Mutter.
Und sie hat Hothose im Hüftgelenk.
Und muss wahrscheinlich bald operiert werden.
Und bald eine neue Hüfte.
Neue Hüfte.
Okay.
Und der Vater hat hohen Blutdruck, aber der fühlt sich wohl,
der nimmt seine Medikamente und ist zufrieden.
Es geht ihm jetzt gut.
Wie alt ist Ihr Vater?
57.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ein Bruder, der ist 30 Jahre alt, der ist gesund.
Und eine Schwester, die ist 27 Jahre alt.
Und die hat auch etwas Asthma, so wie ich häuschnupfen.
Und auch im Frühjahr manchmal Asthma beschweren.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Okay.
Sie sind lählich.
Keine Kinder.
Was machen Sie wählauflich?
Ich arbeite bei einem Rechtsanwalt.
Rechtsanwalt.
Okay.
Aber sich stets bei der Arbeit.
Das ist anstrengend, aber es macht mir Spaß.
Haben Sie Haustiere?
Haustiere? Nein, ich habe keine Haustiere.
Okay.
Frau Schmidt, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe von meiner Seite alles gefragt.
Was glauben Sie, was das ist, was das für Schmerzen sind?
Mein Nachbar sagt, das kann mit der Galle zu tun haben.
Oder ich denke, eventuell Blinder haben.
Kann es auch etwas anders sein?
Ich denke jetzt, dass Sie Blinder haben.
Aber das ist keine feste Diagnose.
Das ist nur Verdachtdiagnose.
Ich muss noch körperlich unter die Unterzugsführung durchführen.
Und einige Läuber unter die Unterzugsführung werden lassen.
Ich habe schon für nächste Woche einen Termin zur normalen Vorsorguntersuchung
bei der Frauenherz.
Aber ja, mal gucken.
Ich kann jetzt genau sagen, ob Sie Ihren Termin gehen können.
Eine letzte Frage.
Ich habe für die Frau Schmidt,
ich habe vergessen,
sind Sie in nächstes Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, das ist schon länger her.
Jetzt bei Corona bin ich nicht viel verreist.
Da bin ich nur in Deutschland kurz etwas verreist,
aber nicht im Ausland.
Okay.
Haben Sie Deutschland oder Verstopfung?
Nein.
Okay, Frau Schmidt.
Das war es von meiner Seite.
Okay.
5 Minuten?
Brauchen Sie?
Ja.
Mach den 5 Minuten.
Alles klar.
Herr Schänoll, bitte fragen Sie,
Ihre Patienten, Frauenanwärm,
für die Differenzialdiagnose.
Danke schön.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Ja, bitte.
Danke.
Petra Schmidt ist 29-jähriger Patientin.
Die sich bei uns seit 2 Tagen bestehende
dumpf Bauchschmerzen im rechten Unterbauch.
Leubter Patienten haben die Schmerzen
per Umliege angefangen,
aber dann sind im rechten Unterbauch gewandert.
Die Schmerzen sind bei 4-5 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Jetzt sind sie bei 7-8 von 10.
Als begleitete Symptome sind die Patienten
überall von 38,6 Grad auf Gefallen.
Wo hat sie die Temperatur gemessen?
38,6.
Und wo?
Im Mund.
Ja.
Okay.
Seit gestern.
An please
An getymłbym.
Pat Wirepatient, kbs Mattia
ente Опobilistin.
Die Patienten hat keine andere Erkrankungen.
Ist das ein dauerhaftes Asthma oder eher ein saisonales Asthma?
Saisonal Asthma.
Okay.
Ja, das seitlich. Nur im Frühling.
Und dagegen nimmt die Patienten Cortison Spray und Asthma Spray.
Die Namen sind nicht erinnerlich.
Okay.
Beide Patienten, keine Operation und Krankenhaus auf den Erkrankungen.
Und sie hat, sie hat allergie, genitis allergie, die sich durch Augen trennen
und Büschme äußert.
Ja.
Und gegen, was ist sie allergisch?
Sie hat auch eine Nüsse allergie, die zu exantem und brennend im Mund hört.
Okay. Hat sie eine auffällige gynäkologische Vorgeschichte?
Ja. Leider habe ich vergessen, die über gynäkologische Frage zu stellen.
Gibt es Geburt, gibt es Geburtenschwangenschaften in der Vorgeschichte?
Nein. Okay.
Die Patientin hat nicht gesagt, aber ich musste etwas mehr fragen.
Ja.
Okay.
Also bei Frauen, in dem Alter muss man natürlich auch immer möglichst
gynäkologische Anamnese erheben und eventuell da auch noch schauen.
Weil Ihre Verdachtdiagnose, Herr Kollege, ist wie?
Der Verdachtdiagnose ist, ob er gut, ob man sitzt.
Ja.
Aber was könnten noch differentialdiagnostisch in Betracht kommen?
Ja, die Transdialdiagnose kommen.
Atmixitis.
Ja.
Und Ovaliatorium und Diwertikulitis und Qualitis.
Okay.
Also Atmixitis muss man auf alle Fälle dran denken und gegebenenfalls
durch ein gynäkologisches Konzil ausschließen.
Ja.
Eventuell noch eine entzündliche Damerkrankung?
Ja, es kann sein.
Kann sein?
Nein.
Ich denke, es ist unwahrscheinlich, aber es gibt ein wenig Möglichkeit.
Hat die Patientin diesbezüglich einer Vorgeschichte,
ob es eine Stuhlbezüglich Stuhl, Unregelmäßigkeiten oder
Schlammauflagerung im Stuhl oder Anämie oder Gewichtsabnahme?
Keine.
Das haben Sie ja schon durch die Fragen.
Eigentlich herausgefunden, stabiles Gewicht.
Zumindest keine Auffälligkeiten.
Okay.
Ich denke, gibt es sonst in der Familie Auffälligkeiten?
Bei den Eltern gibt es da eine auffällige Familienanamnese?
Ja, genau.
Bei der Mutter, der Arterielle Hypertonie,
die Schwester hat leidet an Asthma und Heuschelupfen.
Okay.
Wie Patientin?
Ja.
Also, ihre Arbeitsdiagnose, Verdachtsdiagnose,
Akute Affinities, ist die Patientin nüchter.
Im nächsten Stunden hat sie nichts gegessen.
Ja.
So ist sie wahrscheinlich nüchter.
Gut.
Was haben Sie jetzt vor zu untersuchen?
Ich würde zuerst Vitalparameter überprüfen
und das Blut abnehmen.
Und dann Bauchuntersuchung.
Körperliche Untersuchung.
Und dann natürlich Abdomenpapation,
Körperliche Untersuchung, Labor,
Anhängen einer Infusion.
Die Patientin muss nüchtern bleiben.
Darf nichts mehr essen.
Und auch möglichst nicht mehr trinken.
Weil es kann ja sein, dass wir bald operieren müssen.
Ja.
Sonografie des Abdomens und gegebenenfalls,
wenn wir nicht sicher sind,
vielleicht eine gynäkologisches Konsil.
Ja.
Gut.
Ich würde sagen, bin ich mit einverstanden.
Das können wir so machen.
Kurz zu meiner, ein Kommentar.
Sie haben die Anamnese finde ich sehr gut systematisch.
Erhoben.
Und vielleicht gut die gynäkologische Aspekte ist etwas kurz gekommen.
Da müssen Sie vielleicht noch darauf achten,
dass Sie das noch vielleicht ein bisschen mehr erfragen.
Ich denke mir,
dass das auch gut geht und auch für eine Prüfung gut ist.
Wenn Sie das schildern, versuchen Sie auch.
Das geht aber vielen so,
Ihren Kollegen auch versuchen Sie einfache Sätze.
Nicht zu lange Sätze.
Das wird dann immer komplizierter.
Das dann wieder zusammenzuführen.
Also ruhig sagen, Frau Petra Schmidt ist 29 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 1,75 m groß,
62 kg schwer oder so,
ich habe es nicht mehr genau im Kopf.
Sie klagt seit zwei Tagen über Bauchschmerzen,
Anfangs umbillikal,
um etwas medizinische Fachausdrücke zu benutzen,
umbillikal und dann jetzt einstrahlen in den rechten Unterbauch.
Sie hat febrile Temperaturen 38,3 °C.
38,76 °C, oral gemessen,
also sublingual gemessen, oral gemessen,
um kurz zu sagen,
also nicht unter der Achselhöhle, sondern oral,
das ist ja auch verrestlicher.
Und da eben immer probieren,
noch ein paar medizinische Ausdrücke mit reinzubringen.
Sie klagt über Inapätenz
und etwas nausher,
so ein bisschen rein,
oder asma-saisonales asma-bronchale bei Heuschnupfen.
Sie berichtet dann chronischen Erkrankungen
über saisonales asma-bronchale bei Polynosis.
Um jetzt diesen Heuschnupfen,
Polynosis ist ja der Fachausdruck.
Wenn Sie das so bringen,
wird das alles gut klappen,
das werden Sie gut schaffen.
Wann haben Sie Ihre Prüfung?
Am 26. Februar.
Und wo ist die Prüfung?
In München.
Ja, ich habe da ein gutes Gefühl,
dass Sie das gut schaffen.
Vielen Dank.
Versuchen Sie bei Ihrer Systematik zu bleiben
und lassen Sie sich nicht aus der Ruhe bringen.
Manchmal ist der Oberarzt ja sehr ungeduldig.
Das war ich jetzt heute nicht.
Aber sonst habe ich da ein gutes Gefühl.
Vielen Dank.
Es war zwischendurch ein Kollege,
der, glaube ich, sie darauf hingewiesen,
ich hörte, dass nur Differenzialdiagnose,
ich glaube, ich hole Lithiasis oder so etwas.
Natürlich kann man das auch noch einbringen.
Aber das ist, glaube ich,
jetzt, was Differenzialdiagnose angeht,
reicht es, glaube ich,
wenn Sie eine Differenzialdiagnose
oder zwei aufführen,
in diesem Fall reicht das.
Mehr, mehr brauchen wir, glaube ich, jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Ja, und sonst so können wir das jetzt erst mal lassen.
Und wenn sonst keine großen Kommentare oder Fragen sind,
dann können wir das auch gern beenden.
Ist es für Sie in Ordnung?
Ist es okay für Sie?
Ja, gut.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen viel Erfolg in der Vorbereitung
und allen anderen auch.
Und einen guten Abend und eine gute Zeit.